what are we doing first we're gonna do
the spices first so okay cumin just make
sure that the oil is hot put the cumin
in and
immediately put it and this is yeah and
then put the turmeric in i love turmeric
so much and it just immediately smells
amazing
and then you're going to toss in your
onions
and like the kitchen already smells
amazing oh my god the best
food i'm going to put just a pinch of
asafoetida now will you explain what
that is because i feel like i am an
indian food aficionado and i have to
admit i wasn't as familiar with this
yeah this is what we call the truffle of
indian cooking
because it has it does have a very
strong flavor so a little goes a long
way
yeah
and it's immediately oh it's so fragrant
like garlicky fragrant funky yeah
it's earthy
it's amazing so joe i'm going to put all
the roasted vegetables in here
and a lot of times when people eat
indian food they
sense something in it
but they can't tell what's there and
it's acid that's
secret
i would say for me it's what make makes
my mom's indian food taste like indian
food
okay drew now we are putting some salt
in okay
um
oh now it's time for a little chili
powder
just depends as much or as little as you
want i'll go deep because yeah i think
i'm gonna put all of this
she's putting all of it good i have a i
have a
i have an old palette look at the color
of this you guys i mean that is just so
beautiful
it is so stunning
okay now and now it's ginger
just put the ginger and i'm gonna put
all of it and like a full tablespoon of
ginger i feel like the first time i
tested this off like this is a lot of
ginger but the ginger just like brings
that like freshness and the bite like it
really makes a difference like a bright
infusion yes i feel like with indian
food with my mom's indian food she's
just amazing at achieving balance it's
like okay there's a little richness from
this okay we're gonna add tartness from
the lime juice around freshness from the
ginger
it just tastes like
so complete well and as someone who has
literally learned to cook from cookbooks
and watching cooking shows they always
talk about that balance of acid hence
the lime yes and the ginger just
just
maybe not all of it just a little bit
okay
and then just let it kind of caramelize
at the bottom a little bit
because you like to get that sort of
like pan yeah that's fancier
the book is so full of this great
celebration of life your family the
photos there's just such joy in it i
love the recipes it's really one of my
favorites that means a lot excited
and
i will say it's also been such a huge
success
i was i was really proud to make my very
first raita which is a dish like raita
and mint sauce oh my gosh look at that
caramelization it looks good oh yeah oh
my gosh
you just gotta set it
let me in
all right i'm going in i'm gonna turn
this i'm salivating
and then we are going to you gotta
garnish them
is this is this cilantro cilantro i love
cilantro it's my favorite it's a
polarizing herb i realized that i love
it i love it my sister doesn't like it i
love it it's a it's a battle in the
family
oh my god shall i put some on a plate
okay
i mean i might just do it okay you did
and just
you should you should plate it up okay
you're the mom
oh my god you guys
[Music]
is there enough salt oh
my it's great god
i mean look at that crust on the
potatoes i'm just like
oh i'm in heaven so beautiful
and
instead of cauliflower you can even use
broccoli if you're not
potatoes i've done sweet potatoes that's
really good yeah
it's really one of the most beautiful
dishes i've ever had
and i just savor
the moments of being with mothers and
daughters and keeping traditions alive
and
making choices in your life where you
say i got this from my grandmother i
want to give this to myself and my
family pass it down i mean how proud you
must be of your daughter i watch her
make and it makes me so happy
and like i mean it blows our minds that
these dishes that you know growing up
you know my mom would just make after my
piano practice after my sister's track
practice are now being made by so many
people like my mom and i look at every
photo on instagram of people making it
and it just makes us it like delights us
thank you thank you for having us thank
you for having us
[Applause]
one of my favorite cookbooks and one of
everybody's favorite cookbooks is
available everywhere books are sold
thank you guys
[Music]
you